the bells go rest but I Ranma
welcome back to another episode about
less oh Jesus
then I'm having the best day of my
goddamn life
Oh gets even better alternate path to
the showers
why would I ever want to go in a shower
in the place like this I don't [ __ ]
know okay yeah oh [ __ ] that close the
door you get it all right there's no way
you can find me and why me what did i do
what did I do seriously what did I do
I never [ __ ] with anyone I apologize
what do you want my throat hurts
okay we need to be faster here oh great
run faster you idiot done shot huh
Oh oh nice
hey girl you're coming often kids are
like this
oh we were late lead ha ha I love this
game
not gonna lie we have a love and hate
relationship where is he
this is [ __ ] run for it
huh
that [ __ ] can teleport him and shut up
I'm not a pig shut up you is the pink
oh yeah idiot which way which way
there's the blonde I don't [ __ ] know
I don't hey hey hey how you doing sir
nice
shut up I thank you all what do you want
oh I'm sorry
what stop following me what
bang bang toka is that you my god no
they got you too huh well banked don't
worry we're getting out of here just
gotta climb up here just leave me the
[ __ ] alone man jeez no [ __ ] attention
more thing
what do you want
whoa - idiot watch get off me get off me
ugly [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hell just be
nice to me okay oh god damn it I know
you would be back there
shut up bangs shut up what do you want
huh what do you want an ice cream
well you're not getting it [ __ ]
shut up
wait jump from the ledge hey I'm not I
may not be a yo Lamech swagger yes
[ __ ] yeah that's how we do it in the
pier tango there be a girl on youth
development come for dental not anymore
what you doin hide underneath a bit but
you don't win had the idol hit the bed
girl no blood not going shut up
no one likes you and no one's gonna like
your Facebook page J that's how much
[ __ ] there huh that is an awesome [ __ ]
same [ __ ] problem [ __ ] dick what
is happening oh it's you you little dick
sick you I'm gonna remember that come on
Jerri
I'll remember that one why is everyone
so me on TV out of flushing now Oprah
goddamnit what are you doing okay calm
down you're idiots okay but look say I
followed the blood they said but left to
look for batteries by yes batteries and
the morning star and abiding by the
batteries
did it oh did I do something wrong
mama just killed a man and a girl
against his head oh my trigger that way
today
wait there with wall right there
well more like a pillared grinder I
don't [ __ ] I tried that was a joke
latest animal okay that's a broken as
toilet paper thing oh [ __ ] I ain't going
down this Lois I'm a man I'm having a
bad day okay take batteries we know that
[ __ ] batteries when I'm honest Condon if
I hadn't burned their batteries okay I'm
sure nothing bad will happen in the
sewers breath I'm sure it's all gonna be
good fine I'm sure that one day we'll
meet probably not because well chances
are we're not I know it hurts but so
does love but hey I'm here for you oh
[ __ ] I wish you were here for me though
I don't like this place it's [ __ ]
dark
find a way out of the sewers that's all
they tell you gee thanks I haven't had
my lunch yet by the way game okay
Jennifer has [ __ ] us but that's okay
hi sorry how you doing can I interview
you ha you have a nice nose well I tried
complimenting him that didn't work let's
go here
I don't like this place who made that
noise and someone playing a string
instrument I don't like a string
instrument they are [ __ ] creepy
so we could go there or there you know
what yeah let's go here I don't trust
that place saving yay flush the water by
telling to bowels well as long as not a
buff [ __ ] are you [ __ ] serious did
the game just hear what I said
he doesn't even have nipples
oh that's my defense mechanism and the
worst ever how did I survive this long
hardly the pedophile gene even make it
fragile
I'm fragile [ __ ] you box I'm fragile
you're just a box oh let's go here
yeah we can't go there
what okay but there's about yes
I mean [ __ ] yes us close that [ __ ]
finery good fun good fun I keep saying
I'm enjoying the game but I just want to
point to that in case no one knows
because this is so far oh [ __ ]
probably the most interesting horror
game I ever play
like I never been like oh must play
forever and ever I probably would have
quit long ago with any other game you
see coming here
you're not welcome in my house
don't don't get it undone dun dun dun
dun dun dun all he's not even after me
what a [ __ ] old job not a chip gives
him better speak cute
what you gonna do huh
you're a little [ __ ] the outer world is
probably around here the game didn't
really oh [ __ ]
them skills yet something you ain't got
Oh
Oh God
oh he can't fit in the pipes [ __ ] that
guy is evil like what did I ever do to
him let's make sure he doesn't follow us
high-five say say why do you think why -
I felt like that was a moment between us
it did get that's last vow [ __ ] it
completing [ __ ] in this game is so
rewarding but I might have to [ __ ]
tonight tonight I'm saving it okay I
have a Rachel don't judge okay we got
the two vowels use the ladder Oh to jump
down that's what I try to go before [ __ ]
I'm smart Jesus Christ
yeah that's spiderweb though everything
in this game looks amazing but that's
spider web this is pretty [ __ ]
awesome
no I don't need to reload why do you
hate me why do you have such a nice
house seriously I'm serious
you do like squats is that it no you
can't hear me well that's probably a
good thing okay we need to go where he's
going and that's kind of a problem
Yolo has helped us before but Yolo have
only helps once you know only loves once
I think yo ho yo ho Yahoo I think I got
it I think I do I gotta sneeze
all right this is
and
as his run point what's that guy now we
can go down here yay I'm happy we did
good breasts ready
all right price I'll be enjoying that
episode leave a like if you enjoyed
watching as always I really appreciate
all the support I'm getting bros hey you
want a head bye
let's do a head but a head frist that's
a new thing
1 2 3